[Music]
hi rob this is tessa
calling from st thomas u.s virgin
islands
i want to know from you what's your
favorite virtue
such as like an example is patience
what's your favorite virtue what would
you what virtue would you like to
grow in and what would you like to see
more in the world
have a good one well tessa
see that's what happens when you live in
such a beautiful place like the virgin
islands
you think about beautiful things like
that what virtue
is the most virtuous
um is i'm thinking of like that david
fincher movie the seven deadly sins like
you know you don't want to have
what's what sins sloth see it's the
opposite side of that conversation
it's the um well you mentioned patience
um and i have to tell you i did a little
did my morning meditation and my morning
prayers
um just this morning prayed for more
patience
so clearly
that is something that i would use as to
what i would like to have more of myself
patience for sure
is my thing um
but what is my but that's not my
favorite i don't go oh i met this guy
he was so amazing god you got to meet
him he's so patient
that doesn't really work right i mean
it's a good virtue don't get me wrong
and it's the virtue i want more of but
it's not like a beacon of attraction
i don't think for anybody so what would
that be we'll be the beacon of
attraction
virtue well listen i mean i don't know
if it's a virtue
but i you know i like i like funny
people
i know it's not a virtue it's not
funny people are good uh
uh my new made-up virtue is funny i'm
i'm selling it to you as a virtue
hopefully you buy that um and as for
myself
i would like more patience which is
actually
a virtue